a bunch of questions but uh i like
asking directors a curveball at the
beginning um if you could get the
financing to make anything you want what
would you make and why i'm probably the
wrong person to ask this because
i don't have uh
as of right now i don't have aspirations
to tell a
massive tentpole story um i i
i tend to focus on stuff that
um feels very character driven and kind
of dissect and analyze character and so
um
budget for me
is less of an issue because i i tend to
tell stories of people talking in rooms
and so the the budgets are quite low but
um
yeah i i don't i don't have a i don't
have an answer to that specifically i i
think for me if i'm able to continue
telling
thought-provoking stories that um that
allows an audience to
think for themselves and have their own
ideas that's that's what i like to do
you know so whether that
is is a much bigger budget film or or a
contained smaller film
um
that
it doesn't really matter to me it's all
about
exploring ideas and characters within
those ideas
uh in the in the credits you thank james
gray and david benioff um and i'm just
curious why those two there was other
people but you're really you're really
analyzing nice i i didn't think anyone
stays and stays for the full credits um
i
i have gotten to know both of of them a
little bit um and
i i mean i'm i'm a huge fan of of both
of their work and i feel like whenever i
make a film
um
i try to reach out to in my mind
the most talented
interesting minds i can to get their
feedback
um it terrifies me
sending the film to james gray terrifies
me um because i have such respect for
him and he's so brutally honest
but i really wanted his notes i really
wanted his thoughts and and if he could
give me one note that helped the film
that that i wanted that so
um for both of those guys uh i sent this
film and and was able to have a
conversation with them and yeah it was
it was really special
did you actually uh i i know a bunch of
directors and i i know
a lot of people do what you did with
that in terms of showing it to people
and getting honest feedback did you make
any big changes as a result of feedback
from friends and family
i wouldn't say i made any big changes
mostly because with this film
you have a
a very structured story that you can't
you can't change scenes around it it's
the first time i've ever made a film
where i'm like oh
this scene that i thought was gonna go
here i'll move it ten minutes earlier um
i've done that quite a few times this
film is is so much about in real time in
the process of the situation
so i i don't i didn't make any big
sweeping changes but i got a lot of
really strong
character notes which is is so much of
the dna of this film so i feel like it
really improved by by showing directors
especially because
there were some really interesting ideas
about character
about performance you know do you have
this um and and so i i was really able
to
to get in there and then also
the way in which i shot it um it was
really pre-planned so
there's there's moments where i'm going
back to a visual that in the beginning
of the film represented something that
was you know beautiful and pure and
innocent and then i come back to that
same shot
an hour later and and there's a very
different feeling even though it's the
same
it's the same house it's the same shot
but now all of a sudden the
the place is corrupt and feels tainted
and scary and
so the idea
of showing it to other directors and
getting their feedback to see if that
connected with them
um that was really special to to have
conversations with those guys uh i love
the use of three amigos in the movie
because it is
a a great movie and a great clip but it
also says a lot about those three
characters and what this movie is about
thematically there's a yeah it's a very
good clip how tough was it to get the
rights to use it uh and what were you
going to do if you couldn't get the
rights i i feel like a lot of directors
would have this answer which is
your my mind didn't go till we're not
getting the rights it's like we have to
get the rights you know because one once
that clip the idea of that clip
came into our minds it was like okay
this is
this is the perfect clip thematically as
to what's sort of going on and what
we're exploring in the themes but also
the idea that there's a comedic
kind of
and then also a nod to an era of film
that i grew up on you know i i i watched
that film a hundred times over as a kid
so um but the idea that it's not like a
dramatic scene that's like that that's
trying to really point at this
this theme of have and have nots you
know um
but that there's comedy to it and and
that the characters
would actually laugh in this moment even
though they're in this situation
and then
in that moment jesse's character clocks
that that lily and jason are both
laughing and sort of connecting in some
way
and then that takes the movie into a
different direction like
tying in a a seemingly just funny clip
into something bigger
um
i just loved that idea so
so i i in my mind it was only that clip
um and uh
it it took a minute to to get the rights
to it and many conversations but um
but we we rejoiced when when the the
news came in that all the three actors
signed off and they were we were able to
do it
uh i'm out of time but i just want to
ask you something else real quick just
if i can't yeah
um so uh i love movies that don't answer
all the questions and obviously jason's
character
nobody is you know you never establish
who he is why he's doing this but in
your mind did you have those answers or
did you love the idea that it could be
just anything uh in the back of my mind
i have answers so i'm grounded in some
sort of reality you know but but the
idea of
um the audience
bringing in their own thoughts and ideas
into the film was always how i wanted to
tell it i never wanted to
spoon feed the audience or manipulate
them to feel a certain way about a
character
they're all flawed characters
there isn't a traditional protagonist we
sort of connect and disconnect with
characters throughout the film and so
you know if you believe that
jason is robbing this house for pure
reasons or
you know to pay for a parent's
surgery you know then then then you
should believe that that that's right
you know or if you believe that he's
just as corrupt as
as ceo then then you should believe that
you know so that was always the
intention but
um but yeah in
in the back of my mind i have ideas
which could also completely differ from
the other writers you know we all have
our own ideas coming into it
on that note gotta go congrats on the
movie hope you're making thanksgiving
real soon thank you thanks man
appreciate it